[Applause]
Michelle Obama has more balls than Lance
Armstrong What did Lance Armstrong do to
deserve
that obvious obvious there's no
question
long before the daily wire ever existed
I was drinking with Andrew claven and
now we've come full circle but before we
get to the guest of this episode you
need to go get this game yes or no the
greatest interview show ever in the
history of of recreation is available
right now dailywire.com shop it is the
perfect Christmas present it's ideal for
Thanksgiving it is an a terrific Arbor
Day gift for any holiday of the year go
to dailywire.com shop and you can get
the conspiracy theory expansion pack
which is even better 110 plus new cards
you can find out even more about your
friends and your family and you can you
can destroy those relationships just as
you delve and Plum their depths so head
on over right now dailywire.com
shop Drew hey Cheers To Your Health
thank you very much a very familiar I
should warn you when I drink in the
middle of the day I I do vomit
copiously good well well then you've got
to make sure that you get the questions
right okay or wrong okay because the
rules are if you get the question right
you get to drink and if you get the
question wrong you have to I see there's
a high Stak game the high stakes game
you will move my glass uh to whichever
answer you think I would give give okay
and vice versa and by the way we we
might want to let the audience in on on
something here we know each other very
well yeah we've been in each other's
heads many times I started my career
here yes writing that's as you on social
media doing it so well that and I'm not
joking I used to look at your tweets it
was on Twitter to find out what I
sounded like I would say like I've
forgotten who I am now I
you well thank you very I mean just to
prove it to them yeah you and are so
close we can almost finish each other's
sandwiches okay I'm going to begin then
you'll go and we'll go back and forth
until we're lying on the floor I got it
I'm already lying on the floor yeah
Michael nolles peaked when he was the
cultural correspondent on the Andrew
claven show that's the question that's
the prompt and I'm supposed to say your
your my answer your answer yeah you
peaked when you were I mean okay so I
just have to say what you would say yes
good point I peaked when I became an
international cigar sales that I knew
that was your your big moment uh but you
certainly got that absolutely right I I
thought that was the only thing you've
ever done that entertain me in any way
shape or or informed me in any way in
any way and I was thinking the other day
of how that all began how you gave me my
break in all political media and the way
I know I've never forgiven
myself the way you did it was
because I had seen a movie that weekend
called sausage party about a cartoon hot
dog yeah and you asked me to come on the
show to talk about aformentioned cartoon
hot
dog you you were actually good I
actually put you on the show cuz you
were good you actually were an
entertaining thing what happened to you
I I you know I peaked I Peak is what
happened uh you're up no I still
drinking wait still I know I don't want
to interrupt
that
Michelle Obama has more balls than Lance
Armstrong What did Lance Armstrong do to
deserve that yeah well he got sick he
did get sick right it's too soon to make
a j survive I know that's
cruel obvious obvious there is no
question right I'm not if it had been
some kind of conspiracy theory yeah no
exactly I'm not say I'm not saying Obama
is a
guy you're only mouthing
it I'm mouthing it that's right it's
less was the only way to save the
country is to get married and bang your
wife but only in that
order who writes this I oh you did oh
okay I want you to know I want you to
know I did a book thing for my book The
House of Love and Death which you should
all be B but I did a a thing at the
mysterious Bookshop and it was packed
and people kept coming up to me guys
kept coming up to meet with their
pregnant wife and say see I I did it I'm
saving the
country I thought I thought I didn't
give that Specific Instructions I
thought I'm glad you figured out how to
do it and in that order okay so I've got
to guess how well I know how you would
answer well yeah that's the
obious I got wrong you got it wrong and
do you know only because of the you're
you're generally right but there's one
exception which is religious vocation
there's we also need monks and nuns and
I want to get a point on the board
that's the other thing I want to find
score a point that one goes to me I want
to be very clear on a religious
technicality say outside the Vatican you
know yeah I well what we're going to end
up having to do I mean not us because of
the wives and the kids and everything
but it's going to be like Benedict
running off to the hills you know the
Hinterlands when all of the institutions
are flooded Madness and then you know
things will things will recover or it'll
be the end of days isn't the church like
falling apart is that me I just keep
the the bad news is that the church is
falling apart okay it's a complete
disaster is the Antichrist it is listen
I you've said it I didn't I'm not I I
just thought that was obvious the good
news yeah that's always the case isn't
it you know hasn't it been the to quote
hir bellock I have to take it as a
matter of faith that the church is
divinely instituted one proof for the
non-believer is that no other
institution conducted with such navish
imbecility would have lasted aord what
about the American
government well that made it 200 years
we'll see maybe gets to
2011 okay all right it's my turn right
no it's your turn yeah all right see he
peaked um Cameron winter the thing could
be played by a black guy and it wouldn't
change the character or story but Andrew
made him a CIS white guy for some reason
to say what you would say about
yes
okay
damn right correct yeah of course KT
Cameron's a white
guy what was the question Cameron winter
character in the house of my book that
you're suppos
it's yeah you can't no he what he would
he would be a Latino woman if you were
to make the Disney movie you know a a
producer called me up the just two days
ago and asked me if the movie rights
were and I was talking to him and just I
didn't want to just say to him like you
know I I'm not signing anything until
he's
white I just want to be perfectly clear
here I I didn't want to put him off that
quickly yeah and so he called you which
means that when he hung up the phone is
that when he decided to Google you or
that's what I was thinking well I you
know what I said to him he said where
are you living I told him where I was
living He said why he said I said I work
at the daily wire and and he just got
this kind of little um embarrassed kind
of pout on his face yeah you know so who
knows well it's nice to receive exactly
one phone call about about the movie
right your book absolutely true
absolutely true my my agent who was a
farle guy no longer my agent but he he
read this book he loveed this book yeah
and he said I'm going to sell this book
I said you never sell it I've been
Blacklist he came back months later I've
shown this book to over a hundred people
we didn't even get a nibble and it's so
good and I said because I'm black iist
said no they would never black
no you're you're listed of
color that's right right now go to
goodranchers.com use code nolles what do
green eggs and your Christmas dinner
have in common they both need a ham to
be complete not just any ham but a
spiral cut Heritage pork Masterpiece
from good ranchers that's the kind of
ham that'll steal the show at your
family gathering guess what you get it
for free with any good ranchers
subscription that's a whopping $99 value
that you get for free in your first
order you know what I had last night
juicy delicious chicken you know where I
get my chicken and my steak and all my
meat basically is from good ranchers and
it is just the best stuff out there the
price is unbelievable you get freebies
like this $99 ham it's just completely
insane simply subscribe to any box you
will get your totally free Christmas ham
included in any order the subscription
is amazing get 25 bucks off every order
a free gift in every third Buck and free
shipping on express delivery the best
part is knowing exactly where your meat
comes from and that is through a local
American Farm here's the Scoop
goodranchers.com subscribe today with
code nolles to claim your free Limited
stock Christmas ham before they sell out
act fast this offer won't last forever
head on over to goodranchers.com use
code nesk Wes when you subscribe to get
your free 10 pound Christmas ham don't
settle for the old holiday Fair elevate
your Feast with good ranchers this year
good ranchers American Meat delivered
being Anglican is like playing air
guitar you have an idea what you're
imitating but it's not the real thing
uh it's easy it's easy for me do do you
do you go first when you read it is that
no we could do we could do do it
simultaneously
uh I'm going to say
yes no okay all right look I was on I
didn't know if there was some deep
esoteric you were going to convert swim
the Tyber on this show get the ratings
up I I actually believe that the church
is universal you know that the there are
there are various churches that are that
count the Orthodox Church my particular
Church which is about 15 people you
exactly yeah and none others okay I
guess there is sort of church that one
will be lumped into the ordinary it at
some point sooner or later anyway by the
way we're going to heal the east west
sism in legitimately I'm I'm only half
joking when I say that I think we
actually could heal it I I agree it's
God's Church he'll bring it together
when he's ready yeah you'll be left out
yeah but guys we resolved the Philly o
shut up
Michael no one wants you chasing after
me U me okay here we
go huh someone will eventually leak the
Jeffrey Epstein Client List I better
leave the country yeahuh I mean the rest
of the
Jeffrey um someone will eventually weak
the Jeffrey epon
clients what did you
say wrong I think no really you all so I
think no and you think yes yeah I think
somebody will eventually be it it has
been 60 years since the JFK
assassination true and we were told by
Congressional order we were going to get
all the CIA files in
95 the year of ourl 2023 we get a little
nibble here or there oh maybe they were
doing some surveillance on Lee
Harvey well first of all Lee Harvey
oswal was killed by a communist one
communist guy and all the CIA stuff is
JFK was killed by one communist guy JF
guy oh who were you talking about yeah
well no Lee Harvey oswal and then and
then Lee Harvey oswal was killed by one
CIA py for the
CIA because they didn't want to tell him
that they giving the guy money or
something like that you
know but but the clintons can't live
forever and that's that's really what's
in the world right do do you think
though if I assume Jeffrey Epstein was
mobed up with intelligence I you know
yes I think I think it's almost
guaranteed and will the intelligence
agencies allow that information out
that's a good question that's a fair
question I mean I I think it really does
depend like what what was this we really
don't know like what this guy was doing
like James P I read I actually read
James Patterson's book on the on the
thing you the big mystery writer and
he's you know he's a billionaire so he
does he write his own books even I don't
know no way but he but he gives people
credit for writing them you know but um
I read it and it didn't tell you
anything except like you know what he
would do to these women and I thought
come on what the hell was he up to right
I I want to I actually don't care about
the the women stuff yeah you know like
there's like five things you can do
anyway you know I mean I to quote nor
McDonald you think you invented a six
thing it's really actually just three
and five together but I I would like to
know we know the big I mean we know Bill
Clinton obviously we know uh prince
Andrew we know but but about those other
guys Bill Gates Bill Gates yeah and and
here's another question I have why is it
that Harvey Weinstein and Jeffrey
Epstein both had deformed
genitalia yeah there it's really strange
right is is that something that like
makes you want to like abuse underage
girls right that's right when when it
came out this was totally buried by the
Press but it came out in the Harvey
Weinstein Court dos yeah that he is
vaguely hermaphroditic yes it's a
genital deformity but he he could be
identified as interex really yes which
the the I mean again the interex and her
matism is kind of overstated because
usually you can tell it's one or the
other yeah but uh yeah that I noticed
the pro trans left kind of went real mum
about that one never actually hold on
never look over pay no attention to the
man behind the orange jumpsuit no those
are two very weird stories yeah I mean
Harvey windstein I don't think is as
weird as Jeffrey Epstein and the fact
that fact that he could be murdered like
that that is a story out of su tonius
out of ancient Rome the fact that he
could be murdered in a you know a
facility a safe facility a Max security
facility with cameras and guards and
supposedly a soulmate and and all
Hillary needed was a grouo glasses
that's the craziest
part yeah crazy well to uh yeah the
truth the the late Jeffrey
yeah you can be a good Christian and
actively support the full official
Democratic party
platform yeah it's no possibility it's
not possible it's not you know in
particular ju really just abortion just
abortion you cannot I
mean I I think virtually every
self-identified Christian is on board
with this but also if you're Catholic
the like the popes have been pretty
clear there's there's I just don't
understand how you can call yourself an
actual Christian and like you know like
I can I can understand almost anything
else like you know it's but you know
you're killing babies you're killing
babies I mean it's it's a the right to
life is not just one right among many it
is it is the prerequisite
all the other yeah but but all the other
stuff too I mean even the the the trans
stuff is that is that on the platform I
guess it is these days probably I think
these days you know they're going to
build an idol to uh Osama Bin Laden soon
enough well not only that they may uh
they may actually be like worshiping
Satan they actually do worship s you
know what I'm saying that's the thing
yeah a little a little tough to include
that in your
Christian liturgy you're up all right
here we go
Tessa was far less attractive before
juso wow there's no way to answer this
in a way that doesn't get us in
trouble either we're either we're saying
that our beloved colleague Tess is hot
which is going to get us in trouble with
HR or we're going to say that she wasn't
hot previously so we're insulting the
the woman's looks right how do you I
don't know how to answer that I know how
to answer
I know how I would now also one way you
answer will make our Advertiser really
happy and one way will not make we'll
we'll make our Advertiser angry yeah if
we I know but there's only one right
answer okay all right let's
see so on the question was or the
statement was Tessa was less was far
less attractive before
Jen
okay well I know your
answer but I'm going to say you're wrong
I'm going to say Tessa was far less
attractive far less attractive because
because Drew jenus cell came on right
around the time that Tessa got married
yes and Tessa who is a physically
beautiful woman she she became all the
more beautiful actually when she was
married they were talking about soul
well you know I just don't want to get
in trouble Drew I don't come on such a
whimp I can't
just coward well in any case I'll drink
to forget the question here's to Tessa
to Tessa and to Jus and to J yourell
yeah she does love this stuff mhm right
now go to genucell.com I've got a
holiday gift idea that will make you the
hero of the Season we all know that the
Christmas season can be hectic the
shopping the cooking the never ending
list of things to do but I have
discovered a gift that is both
thoughtful and transformative that is
the gift of genell skincare from now
until Christmas genell's most popular
package has a special discount just for
our listeners at Jus cell.com
kwl treat yourself and your loved ones
to the best skincare in the world those
troubling forehead wrinkles Fine Lines
skin redness and sagging joyline will
disappear right before your eyes with
jus cell's most popular collection genus
cell promises immediate effects you will
see results in less than 12 hours
guaranteed or your money back you
deserve erve to look and feel your best
this Christmas season you know I love
the founder of this company cop a
Christian from Egypt left for the
American dream I love the product they
use only the top quality ingredients go
to Jus cell.com
ncwl to get this incredible discount
every order today is instantly upgraded
to free express shipping Jas cell.com
today
okay it is more likely that the Great
Pyramids of Giza predate the flood and
were built by Nephilim or with other
Supernatural Direction then that the
prevailing narrative pushed by the
experts is
true no come on you made me you were so
confident in mine that I cuz I know
you're nuts yeah that's true no you're
right you're right a darn I'm going to
lose this game all right uh can you
actually lose this game is this keeping
scor I am con it's somewhere look at our
hands this
great the whole
like there we are
um if you told me yeah that the pyramids
are 50,000 years old I I would believe
you if you told me that the pyramids
were built by by Pagan civilizations
just worshiping demons and the demons
actively guiding their hands I would
believe you I'd be much more likely to
believe you than if you told me you know
they had like a lever or something they
had a bunch of slaves pulling like
Jewish
guys Jewish guys aren't that beefy I
mean the ones in the IDF are yeah
exactly maybe it's that okay yeah all
right all right maybe maybe I keep an
open mind all
right
I'm glad whether I got that right or
wrong I'm glad that we could at least
yes and and I and I have to say that I'm
shocked that we're actually keeping
score yeah I'm not I mean I don't I
don't see the score
anywhere to more emphatically push back
on the woke nonsense in Disney's
upcoming live action Snow White in the
Seven Dwarves Jeremy should go all the
way against political correctness
entitled It Snow White and the Seven
midgets
is midgets the least politically correct
word for a little person no because a
dwarf and a are two different
things are they yes what's the
difference one one is a mythical
Woodland creature one is a sort of short
fell no no one is a short person and the
other is a short person but is kind of
um
malformed I do believe there's a
difference so right one one has sort of
ordinary proportions and one is oh
interesting that's true I've noticed
that distinction yeah
um I think it should be called Snow
White in the seven white
guys Snow White in the seven perfectly
ordinary straight white men even
whiter Snow White in the whiter guys
okay so the answer is no have to but our
I think our solution would be really yes
of course in fact it should just be
called white white and the white white
white been calling the new one sand
beige sand beige and the Seven tall
men ex ordinarily proportion ordinarily
proportion tall man Michael nolles
embracing the dad bod in his early 30s
yeah real nice real I think I look
actually pretty good thank you uh
embracing the dadbot in his early 30s is
disgusting and disordered it's kind of
like if Michelangelo saw a marble block
and said ah let's just slap some pasta
and Whiskey on it it's perfect the way
it is who wrote this who
WR
uh I mean insulting but undeniable so I
got your answer
right I'm trying to think about what I
think about
this all right we can put it in the disc
fine
uh I'm two minds here one I think it's
weird that men obsess over their
physique like women so men like gy rat
men I think actually are a little too
Vain and somewhat
womanish but the old ancient
Greeks they understood that virtue is
not merely an intellectual right
Endeavor it it's a it's physical as well
and if I really were interested in full
AR I would LIF a wait every now and
again so I agree I agree I I have I have
to say that especially uh some of us
those of us who have aged it is a good
thing to sand shine
yeah yeah I because I the thing is I
don't I don't watch what I eat yeah you
smoke and I well that's actually the
that's the plus because it suppresses
the appetite so I don't become a big fat
guy so that's the one Health Benefit I
have plus we know nicotine is good for
you did you know that great it is no I
was talking to uh your son no relation
to Spencer clay
and he told me that he believes we will
live to see a day when nicotine is
looked on as a health substance he does
believe that he's what contradicts him
is after the discovery of America where
they started to send home tobacco every
English king died of jaw
cancer that's a little well yeah but
look that's an
anomaly isn't that correlation is not
starting to realize correlation is
causation it's like a lib slogan they
say true is it me you you me all
right allowing attractive women into the
workplace is more dangerous than letting
a pitbull babysit your
toddler well you're you're pretty
outspoken against pit bulls
too it's a question is it more danger
yes yes Yeahs obviously of course it's I
I assume we're violating a lot of nlrb
statutes here but it's it's not good for
anybody I don't think women should be in
the workplace at all of course not like
until you know maybe for like a year
before they get married having children
that's like it's ridiculous it's it's
for what does it make women happier no
no and like this this thing where they
come back to work after they have
children stay home take care of your and
and by the way eventually your children
grow up and then you can start to enter
the workplace you any W disturb yeah I'm
not I'm not opposed to but but you're so
right like for for what I have
for every fictional story I hear of a
woman who really just wanted she her
dream was to make widgets and she was
kept from that by the patriarchy I have
so many female friends who got lured
into all the BS put your career first
and and you know then they say oh they
despair they say I can't find a husband
I can't get married I can't have kids
you know I was I was at my
priest's birth birthday party and this
woman sat down across from me and just
started talking to me about her life and
she had a baby a new baby and her
husband and she said you know they told
me to go to work and then get married as
if getting married was easy as if it
were easy to play somebody she said it
was so hard and I you know like I didn't
care about my work at all and all I care
about is my baby and they all you know
why wouldn't you why wouldn't you the
most how much of work is like you know
nonsense you're raising a child and you
know when you know I remember I I was
talking I guess I was talking to my
father-in-law years ago I said well what
what thing that you've done are you
proud of stuff and he said my kids no
question my kids and I thought as a guy
in his early 20s I thought okay that's
just the pat answer that an old guy
gives okay whatever and then I had a kid
and within 5 seconds I realized oh right
nothing look not to downplay my blank
book which is a magnopus and will endure
for ages but the cigars are good man the
cigars thank you the cigars are good and
those you set on fire and then they turn
to Ash but I I was uh at the birth of my
first son my wife is delivering the baby
I'm delivering my manuscript on my book
with Words which I really labored over
and cared a lot about they were both due
on the same day you did you roll them up
actually and I thought oh you're
delivering your baby I'm delivering my
baby that I've been working on for nine
months or really over over that probably
double that time and I thought and I'm
not downplaying my book I think it's a
good book this is nothing this is
nothing compared to what is happening
it's our it's our pain ale imitation of
what they're doing you yeah yeah yeah
and and the thing is I really do feel
that because of that we as men as a as a
a breed of people have purposely
denigrated what women do yeah oh she's
just she's you know they just take care
of the house and I it's like all I know
is like go up to a guy who's bigger than
you and insult his mother and when you
recover in the hospital right you think
this is something that matters to people
people adore their mothers yes yeah
that's that's a great Point well now
they're
nannies it's just capitalism
H I think it's you I'm up yeah I've read
all three of the Cameron winter
Mysteries I can I I know this for a fact
I hey okay hey I I think you I think
you've probably read them now In
fairness I have I have maybe read more
Andrew claven novels willing certainly
I've willingly read more Andrew claven
novels than maybe all the novels I've
ever read combined I mean it's you you
have finished one of my novels oh yes I
no i' I've actually read a number not a
lot like I don't know like five or tops
you know right that's actually a lot
yeah but
I I don't I just I'm not saying I hate
novels no you don't read novels I don't
read them I just even great novels even
sometimes for the book club I you know
I'm assigned novels I do it for and and
they're every time I finish a great
novel I think oh that was great every
time I finish one of your books I'm not
puffing you up they're they're just
excellent and they're like beautiful I I
have I've this is going to sound so yeah
go gay I've been I've I've like teared
up read at the ends of your books it I
know and I'm this is a
confession but and yet
still then I put it down I say wow that
was truly edifying perhaps even
sanctifying experience well done with
that bye okay time to go read some other
dry philosophy on nonsense yeah there
some men like they don't understand what
if if they understood what novels were
for yeah then they would read them more
but we're a dumb country so don't
understand that yeah yes but novels
actually do if you read them right if
you read them with a True Heart they
actually make you a better person yes I
did I just ordered because when we go
out have a stogy maybe a couple of
coca-colas you'll say you have to read
this book or that book and then I I
often order it immediately but you never
read they just pile up so I've got the
one the monk book oh yeah well that's a
fun book yeah what's that book called
the monk the monk by um it's by Monk
Lewis is Lewis yes and that's it's on my
nightstand and you would like that
because it's a really interesting
Catholic
novel all right that pitches it up a
little yeah I'm working my way up I'm
reading the Father Brown stories yeah
they're great I I can do 20 pages of
fiction at a time pretty soon you
know it's kind of why I like poetry I do
read poetry poetry is great and poetry
because it tricks me because I think of
a poem is like 14 lines and then you get
to the end of Dante and you think
goodness gracious and it takes a long
time it takes a long time to read a poem
yeah but I do love poetry I love I mean
poetry had a day yeah and then it died
yeah like I know
that I was trying to compose one right
now like a high coup but take too long
me right you're up all right here we
go
it is more likely that we will fall into
World War III in the next 10 years than
not uh yes
yeah I can make my argument if you like
go
ahead the term thusi trap is overplayed
and most international relations jargon
is is overplayed but uh Graham Allison
the Harvard political scientist makes
makes this case that uh of the last
however many 19 or 16 to 20 Global
conflicts 3ars of them have uh ended in
war meaning when a when a rising power
confronted a dominant power the
consequence 3/4 of the time has been in
War uh so now we face this with the US
and China China I think is trying to
head it off and China just just recently
came out and said we the question is do
you want to be our partner or our
adversary uh if you want to be our
partner there's it's a big wide world
there's room for both of us if you want
to be our adversary and stop us from
rising you know basically we're going to
go to war and I I think the United
States is bellicose not intentionally so
but we we just kind of stumble into Wars
and we're the dominant power on Earth
and so the odds are already so stacked
against us I don't I don't see how and
the the civilizations are so different
here in the US and China I don't
compromise I don't see there's no
compromise yeah my argument is that we
don't destroy our homes until we leave
we destroyed Europe after we were gone
you know and so and so I I I think that
when the minute Elon Musk sets up a
community on Mars yeah then we'll have
World War I we'll just blow the planet
to pieces you don't think though do you
think we could have a World War III
without blowing the planet to Pieces
yeah we could um we could maybe yeah I
mean because because nuclear
weapons could be used in such a way that
they made the planet unlivable but they
could also be used in such a way that
Millions die and you know right this is
the thing people think of it you know
one nuclear bomb goes off and the but
that's not actually not how it works
right right but but especially you know
when you've got a the first major war in
Europe in Ukraine then you've got this
outbreak of war in the holy land that
could Escalade though that's the scarier
one to me well it's way scarier and it's
already involves what like six powers or
seven powers and maybe more soon yeah
uh wait so did I get that right or you
got it wrong I got it wrong
ah where's the where's the
score yeah I don't know but they are my
hands it's like a
Fed when you're blue and you don't know
where to go to why don't you go
apparently you're winning by one tell
I'm winning by more than that wait a
minute listen how greedy he is okay
being invaded by pestilence or being
bombarded with noise and production
issues on a project is a good sign that
you were doing something me meaningful
ah of course yeah happens the
caterpillars yeah the caterpillars yeah
and then was this was after we when we
did when we did another kingdom and I
felt it was a sort of godb born you know
and the reason I say this is because I
was sitting there thinking I had written
a novel that didn't work and I had the
flash I was going to have to throw it
away and suddenly the entire another
kingdom story came into my mind at once
which has never happened to me before
since ever ever happened just the whole
thing bang first and the day that I
finished it that my house was overrun by
caterpillars and then remember we
started to record it yeah everything
went wrong constantly we had to
re-record whole episodes yes the whole
thing was and um and then when I moved
and I was writing and and another uh I'm
sorry the the uh the truth and Beauty
was coming out and I I was getting ready
to promote it and everything like this a
book that was clearly a gift from God
that book first time that uh our Lord
alongside John Keat had ever made
theist my my office was invaded by wasps
so every day I would come in and there
would be five six wasps in the place and
I thought like well yeah of course yeah
they were episcopalians and they were
yelling at you it's too romanish right
yeah I was doing an interview with an
exorcist father yes remember this yeah
we sitting there yeah and usually on
those I was told I was going to have 25
minutes of no audio problems
guaranteed so we're talking maybe seven
minutes goes by oh there's some audio
problem got a cut cut okay sorry Father
rehill okay all we're back up again
seven minutes goes by same thing this
goes on three four at least four times
probably and then I look at him he's a
very calm man very grounded
fell I said father does this happen to
you often Michael it's a story of my
life and I said okay next time it
happens just roll just roll right
through it I don't don't cut for any
reason didn't happen again really rest
two hour interview didn't have it again
that's
funny well yeah you know as you and I
have often said to one another in the
midst of some long conversation Andor
drinking about this stuff is real it's
real that's the it's still surprises me
it's real me too me too because we're so
trained to not believe it yeah but it's
obviously real yeah right in the same
way that like mental illness and being
demon infested are kind of the same
thing just from seeing from right yeah
like I I'm not saying there's I'm not
saying that I'm totally confident that
that they're never separate yes but like
yes there would seem to be a lot of
similarities be like a V diagram like a
V di like K Harris slops yeah diagrams
you're I oh it's me huh all
right it is more beneficial for young
men or women to listen to Andrew Tate
than read everyday
feminism that's our Snicker you know
exactly exactly more beneficial for
young men or women to listen to Andrew
Tate
um I what I would
say I'm going guess what you
[Music]
would yeah yeah I grudgingly I'm not I'm
not because Andrew Tate deres his power
from saying something that is true that
he dedicates to evil the thing that he
says that is true basically is that a
woman will follow a strong man even if
he abuses her before she gives her self
to a weakling who pays her all kinds of
feminist respect so he's saying a true
thing so somewhere in there is a true
thing that he is using he's exploiting
for evil right CU When good people lie
the evil people get the truth and that's
the power right but everyday feminism is
just a joke I mean it's like you know
right and that that's more poison the
only way that could be edifying is if
you you go in realizing what what a joke
it is and treat it like opposite day I
used to use it when I was writing had to
write four satires a week it was like
cheating it was it was it was the
writing four times a week the hardest
single creative act I've ever done and
sometimes I would just take every day F
just read it
yes yes it's like hey can I copy your
homework it won't be too close to what
you wrote you change two words in
everyday feminism yes because Tate
reminds me look I hold out hope that
Tate will figure out figure things out I
mean he's a he's a little up there you
know he's not 22 but uh you know it's
never too late uh but it it reminds me
that the greatest Saints of History
could have been the worst Sinners and
vice versa the worst sinners in history
that's awfully nice of you I just mean I
mean he's Muslim now you know he yeah
for now maybe that's his like if a guy
goes from being an atheist being a
Muslim to being a Christian right yeah
that's great I'll take at least you know
the Muslims know that God exists no
that's true that's true as as one of
them actually a chief Town Chieftain
said to me in Afghanistan we can talk to
the Americans because the Russians had
no God they were animals yes yeah
exactly and I but I it seems to me you
know people have different capacities
and some there there are great and you
know enormously great many wickedly
great people in history and it seems to
me that you know if one of the worst had
if a Stalin or somebody had just gotten
his will and his intellect right gone in
the right direction he could have been
one of the greatest Saints of History
likewise I think you know uh I don't
know St St Benedict or somebody he could
have been one of the worst Sinners and
he turned the wrong way you know your
argument is good I'm not sure it applies
to tape because he's kind of a you know
he's a pimp you know it's like he's a
pimp he's a pimp though he he says he
gave up pimping yeah probably because it
ain't easy but I don't know I mean you
know he also lied about that though he
lied and seemed tried to make it seem
like he had been doing that much longer
ago and I mean that really wicked stuff
I admire I admire your open-heartedness
I try listen I'm I I legitimately am
yeah you
a flaw is is a bit of optimism yeah and
I don't I know optimism is bad I know
it's bad it's not it's like pessimism
two sides are the same point but seeing
seeing the full capacity of the human
person I think is actually a good thing
that's that's yeah I I will praise you
though I'll be disappointed perhaps in
this case probably but yeah but still
okay nice nice effort you get an
E I would be okay with a female
president oh this one's going to get us
in
[Laughter]
trouble I would be okay with a fale
question what yeah well it depends on
what the meaning of okay
[Laughter]
is uh it would be okay I'll say I'll say
yes no I can still live a holy life I
hope and go to Heaven someday so I guess
I'd be okay well Margaret Thatcher yeah
I mean the exception yeah yeah you're
right I mean we're very can you think of
one other example ever in hisory no um
wait one Queen Elizabeth maybe well
she's a queen I I consider a monarch
different than a you know Prime Minister
President let's see Maggie
fasher Liz
truss um you know I believe and this has
nothing to do with the capacities of
women actually I believe that when women
take over a profession the profession is
over that's tell so when women become
anchor women the TV news doesn't matter
anything movie directors and it's not
yeah exactly it's not because
because women can't do it it's because
men do it first yeah they do everything
first and then they see something new
come along and they clear out and that's
when the women move in right and so I
would just assume Angela Merkel right
the end of Europe right that was the end
that she ended Europe I mean it's like
the Germans that took the Germans three
tries they thought like well we'll we'll
just invade then they thought well we'll
have Hitler we'll just kill everybody
that didn't work and then they said how
about a woman
just destroy open up the gates here we
go LEL the continent
yeah so it's hard it's hard to believe
you know like but and and we don't have
a parliamentary system which is what
takes to throw up a Churchill or a
Margaret Thatcher right so probably
would' be screwed but you you have to
hold out the theoretical hope yes and we
and it's really just like it's s sort of
like answering I'd be okay if the Hun
invaded and beheaded us all you know
like I I'd be my okay pess is not
contingent on the political
circumstances of this Fallen World guess
what I'm saying you're up I'm up all
right Casablanca is better than the
Godfather and they could both be
improved on if they were written and
directed by young black lesbian women of
color oh wait that's two two let's take
the first one first all right cablanca
is better than the Godfather kaso is
better than the
Godfather
have you seen b of course
no no no oh Casablanca is so much oh
look Casablanca is great I'm not I'm not
knocking but it's not great it is the
great film it is certainly among the
great films I just recently Revisited
the Godfathers it's the greatest movie
except for
cust look I'd incl I was if I actually
had to picked the greatest movie ever I
would I would throw in there mostly
because I like acting so I look for
acting uh I would throw a street car
great great I would I would maybe throw
on the waterfront yep I would I would
throw uh the
Searchers half the thing that takes
place back at the house is not that is a
little weak okay I would throw
in maybe throw in The Man Who Shot
Liberty Balance yeah that's great maybe
maybe that's like maybe like second tier
going with the wind certainly would
throw and Gone With the Wind you know so
there but I I I'm now of the opinion
other than my favorite movie Me Myself
and Irene if I had to taking obviously
that Masterpiece aside I might be
willing to say that the Godfather the
first one the first one is the great one
yeah is it might be the greatest movie
ever made yeah I think it's I think it's
the greatest movie ever made except for
except for Kasa Blanca okay now hold on
now the second question oh yes the
second part of you don't want to lose
the second part of it they could both be
improved on they were written and
directed by young black lesbian women of
color
obviously I don't want to get cancelled
I want to keep my
show so yes because because the thing is
young black lesbian women of color do
everything better because white men are
the worst people on Earth yeah except
for the lack of talent
I you got to cut you got to cut this
part out don't I want to keep my show
man okay uh I'm up all
right Donald Trump is a good
man
H wow I know what you would
say that's
correct you're you're were right too it
I I know why you said it to you would
say to why would I say you're a lying
do
I obviously am accepting the
anthropological fact that none is good
but God I'm obviously accepting the
Fallen both accept that right I think
relative so we're talking relative to
presidents and politicians I think
actually relative to our degraded state
of politicians and and leaders I think
he's in the upper 50% in terms of his
virtue
actually I think he raised basically
good kids I look he got divorced he's
had all sorts of problems he I think
he's run a business actually pretty
honestly he seems to you know it's funny
that when the one thing about these
indictments is they point out that he's
never really doing anything all that bad
yes I mean the guy was doing real estate
in New York I know they're charging him
with nothing yes even even in his showas
career I think about the evil hideous
things people do in showz what did he do
he slept with some supermodels which is
like the cost that's like the first
thing you do when you get into Big Show
Business I think I I'm not I'm not
defending all the bad things but even in
his kind of uh con Manny ways you know
which have been caricatured so much
there's a kind of honesty to it yeah no
you you're get those are not the things
that bother me about him I mean when he
was running the first time I said this
is the first postchristian
candidate and he was a guy who didn't
care he treated people like garbage
which by the way was bad Politics on top
but I don't know I was just at the
Reagan Ranch I just gave a speech at the
Reagan Ranch I was thinking about Reagan
and by the way you know he was a
womanizer and all this stuff and you
know but but he as a politician he was
So Graceful so of course of course and
they told me like that that they needed
to add paving at the top of the ranch
for safety and he didn't want to do it
because he didn't want to spend the
public money on his safety and I just
thought yeah that's another time well
you go when you go to the ranch which is
pretty cool because it's owned by yaf
and so it's it it even has to be zoned
as a private space
it's cool and he kept you know coffee
cans full of old nails and screws cuz he
didn't want to buy new ones you know and
he so no the the man obviously had such
class and Grace yes for even by the
standards of his time but also it was
the 80s and that was a more graceful and
classy time you know and I just think so
yeah great time he is a he's a better
man yeah compared let mean think about
this we're living in the the age of Joe
Biden and AOC and Pelosi no it's yeah
I'm grading on a curve what I say that
is a big curve uh just it you're up I'm
up you last one for some people horror
films metal music or sexually themed art
are morally fine to create or
enjoy wrong put a point up baby let's go
uh the or is what does it for me yes
sexually themed yeah I mean it shouldn't
be pornography but but sexually themed
is obviously fine of course and horror
films are not horror films I think can
be can be quite good there's some great
hor the exception to me if it had been
an and my answer probably would have
been no because metal music metal music
I don't think is actually defensible I
you know I know so little about metal
music it just the sound of it sounds
just the name of it sounds there what I
know of it comes from Plato okay and was
he a big metal guy he was a huge metal
fan
yeah it was with like
Bas Bala clavas bakala no hold on I'm
That's The Salted seab bass c
um you know percussion music generally
bypasses the rational faculty and this
is why Plato said you got to watch out
this is why alen Bloom said Don't listen
to rock music and nettle by taking out
discipline and control and uh Melody and
harmony for that matter and by being
entirely percussive I I do think I'm
with the old fuddy duddies going back to
Plato I think it it arouses the base
passions and is actually not ever
edifying well see here's the thing I'm
willing to dismiss all music after
1958 so so you get two years of Elvis in
there
okay okay hey wow I mean I just you know
the the the lyrics I I just was in the
gym and I'm on the elliptical and I
usually find something to watch and
there was a Fred a stair movie yeah on
on TV and I started watching this movie
first of all the still Joy no one could
make anything today no one including me
could make anything today that just
distill Joy at that level just sat there
with this stupid smile on your face yes
and then the songs were like you know
there's this great song uh let's face
the music and dance so simple so
condensed you know and just like and and
just on the bridge of poetry but not
trying to be poetry cuz I believe this
is what I believe about music I believe
it's actually bad poetry like you know
they say Bob Dyan they gave Bob Dyan the
Nobel Prize and I thought yeah if poetry
is now a decadent art you know which it
is so so it is yeah but but I just I
just don't think any music pop music
yeah is good at no I think I mean I when
I compare the music from the teens 19
teens through the 50s yes to 60s and
later on the other day I was playing you
know I play my ukulele or a guitar or
something almost every night maybe piano
a little impressed by the thank you I
you know I I play every instrument every
instrument of this the sun other than
drums at the level of a 14-year-old I've
never progressed above that that was
when I stopped but I was I was struming
on the ukulele and I because I saw a
great bit of red fox singing All of Me
you know all of me why not take all of
me you know and so I was I was just
plucking it out on on uke and the
progression I realized is kind of a it's
a Charming progression go C E7
A7 D minor and it's kind of hopping
around over there you know and then it
kind of closes on a G7 so the five and
then goes back to the one and so I'm
playing that I said that sounds kind of
familiar I realized it's another song
that Clapton kind of popularized but
it's a much older song which is nobody
knows you when you're down and out
nobody knows you when you're down and
out it's almost the same progression and
it was it's clearly just a popular
progression of that era but it's comple
there's actual complexity to it and then
I think well what is modern rock music
modern rock music DF right yes I mean
it's it's three chords it's three chords
it's it's 145 maybe you throw in a six
there which is the relative minor maybe
if you want to be fancy but that's it
and so even just you know all of me why
not take all of me can't you see I'm no
good without you this is not you know
the highest degrees of poetry but at
least there's some something happening
in the there's some sophistication going
on in the music if it's
just you know you just think like well
okay that's every song since
1962 G the Simplicity of little lyric
yeah mask the sophistication you know
you took the part that once was my heart
is actually a sophisticated lyric right
and like you listen to No Cole Porter
music all one syllable words you know I
was watching the other day uh what is it
the one that takes place on the ship oh
oh
um yeah that one yeah that one yeah and
uh all through the night all one Sil
Wars all through the night you know and
and and when Dawn comes to awaken me
you're never there at all it's just just
so beautiful it's unbelievably great
right and I I hate to sound like a fdy d
because I understand those they they
don't speak just in the same way I
believe that abstract art is crap but it
does speak into its time so it is I feel
the same way about rock music you could
not write those songs today and make
them mean anything you know because they
actually Express something I'll go
further even on the abstract art point I
I have a soft spot for Dada really I do
in the sense that I think think it
speaks into its time and tells you
something you know and and it's like
evil and it's an evil time you know
that's that is the problem I mean and
but you're right that is Art it is Art
yeah you know and I I do feel that way
about rock music it is Art yeah as
opposed to what's happening now like I
mean I have absolutely nothing against
Taylor Swift I don't think she's harmful
in any way but not art you know it's
like speaking the one the positive I'll
say about Taylor Swift though
is because I don't get it I want to see
the of her concert tour and the women
all the women in the office were
spending zillions of dollars to get the
tickets she is so normal yes she's
pretty but she's not she's not beautiful
yeah no she's but she's pretty and she
doesn't have a ton of tattoos and she's
her like crazy hair or whatever she's
just like pretty and she sings about her
ex-boyfriends it's the most basic
relatable girl experience ever and she's
Greatful she thanks her fans she's nice
she's like nice you know and in another
age
she'd be playing you know a local bar
somewhere in pville but in our age which
is so profoundly bizarre and
abnormal just a little taste of
normality I think is is gold well you
know she reminds me not in in that way
but uh when Madonna was like
unbelievably big yeah I used to think
like her music and her songs are like
this much better than everybody else and
I feel the same way about Taylor Swift
like you listen to everything and it
just goes by you hear a Tor s song you
sort of tap your feet Shake It Off shake
it off and that that one song of hers
that I actually half likee as much as I
like any mod song Like We Are Never Ever
Getting Back Together you know just I
just think that's funny you know even
there something very wholesome she had a
song I didn't know her songs until I saw
this mie some I recognized in the movie
but I can't believe you went to this
movie I I was assigned to do it it was a
labor of Labor not a labor of love it
was a labor of work it's love of Labor
yes and there's one about it's her like
like sexy song where she's doing her
like hot dance but even that she goes I
don't know the words but it was
something to the effect of the things we
do you know when we're together and the
things we do at night in my dreams and I
thought even that is kind of wholesome
cuz it's it's a degree removed it's not
like oh yeah baby put me up against the
wall it's like I'm just dreaming it's
not wack yeah exactly you know yeah yeah
I well to Taylor Swift to Taylor Swift
and did I win the game Mr Davies no you
guys I did yeah
that's right this is a here we go this
is stop the steel all over again we go
this is great sitting
across I feel we both won Drew in a
spiritual way yes now do we have time
for a cigar I I won in the sense of I'm
getting to leave yes that's true oh my
God no I have to go what I have to catch
my I think wait a minute let me see yeah
do I nah you can skip it no I got a
little time here we go we're going to go
have a cigar see you next time
dailywire.com shop go get the game
also buy his book yeah the book is that
the house of Love and Death Buy it get
it it's good it's good see you next
time